welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to Avengers endgame is right around
the corner and naturally the Internet is
rife with speculation about what could
happen in the film there's been a
handful of early screenings set photos
and clips so I thought I'd piece
together everything we know so far about
the movie to tell you what will happen
in the first two acts this is all pretty
watertight but take everything with a
pinch of salt as the Internet is still
well the internet from here on out its
full spoilers ahead so if you don't want
to know anything about the movie then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I hope you enjoyed the
video now sit back relax and let's get
into everything we know so far about
Avengers endgame okay so the opener for
the film is pretty much 100% confirmed
due to the fact that a good chunk of it
was shown at CinemaCon apparently the
scene which takes place in the first 10
minutes of the movie showcases Tony and
nebula adrift in space with little
chance of survival
Tony records his final message to pepper
and wonders if you ever make it out of
the situation there are flashbacks to
the cave from the original Iron Man and
this opener serves as sort of a
reimagining of its time there as the to
try and get back to earth now how they
get back is slightly contested so though
I'd give you the two versions that have
seen publicise the most in Beijing one
apparently Tony uses pieces of nebula to
repair the ship and that's how the two
make it back the second version which
seems a lot more likely involves the two
discovering some Analects batteries that
Rockets stole during the course of
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 and they
use those to repower the ship either way
both sources agree that after they star
the engines the title card comes up the
next part comes from an early screening
of the film and that's been verified by
quite a few sources on reddit in the
scene following the title card we see
thousands on Titan 2 along and medic
the ghost of Gamora appears and says
that she forgives him for his actions
and states that he was right before she
disintegrates and shells that it's just
an ass using a reality stone to make
himself feel better
this not only shows that Dallas has some
doubts over whether the snap was the
correct cause of action to take but it
also confirms that the Infinity Gauntlet
still works next we cut to ant-man who
is hurtling through the quantum realm he
sees visions of the past future and
present before eventually escaping but
landing a few weeks after the snap has
happened this comes into play later and
is one of the main plot aspects that
almost every source is confirming
ant-man gets the band from the carpark
and sneaks up into New York City flash
to Rhodey and Captain America as snap
support meeting in which the latter
clearly hasn't moved on we follow the
two back to Avengers HQ and there's some
establishing shots of NYC that show the
damage that the slap caused
unfortunately as the snap wiped out half
of all life a lot of things like trees
insects and bacteria were destroyed so
the ecosystem of the planet is in
turmoil Thor is visited by Barkery and
the two discussed fighting Thanos as
soon as possible
Valkyrie dissuade him from doing this
and says that you shouldn't attack
before he's ready which is when she
confirms that the surviving as Guardians
have found a new place to live on earth
on a remote island rocket has joined
them as he's an alien - which is when we
get a signal from the benitar that
nebula and Tony are incoming they arrive
on earth
Tony reunites with pepper and heads
towards the Avengers base rocket holds
hands with nebula as he's super
depressed that all of his friends are
now dead back at the Avengers base a
computer alarm sounds and the group code
to see that Fury's beacon has stopped
transmitting the message that led them
to it in the first place this scene was
shown at the end of Captain Marvel so we
can confirm this is how it goes down
Tony thought nebula and rocket then
approached Avengers HQ but Thor senses
an infinity stone nearby and they
prepare for a fight with Thanos as they
saw into the compound which brings them
head-to-head with Captain Marvel there's
a nice little action scene that gets
broken up by The Avengers stating that
she's an ally and they start to discuss
their plan Thor say that as Captain
Marvel gives off the same energy as an
infinity stone that they can use it to
track down oz Rhodey and banner believe
that nothing can be
but Stephen etosha and now joined by
Captain Marvel believe that they can
take the fight back to the character
this is all been confirmed by the clip
that was shown on Good Morning America
and then released by Marvel which I'll
now play he used the stones again we'd
be going in short-handed you know he's
still got the stones so so that's gonna
use them to bring everyone back just
like that yeah just like that even if
there's a small chance that we can undo
this I mean we owe it to everyone who's
not in this room to try if we do this
how do we know it's gonna end any
differently than it did before because
before you didn't have me hey new girl
everybody in this room is about that
superhero life and if you don't mind my
asking where the hell have you been all
this time there are a lot of other
planets in the universe and
unfortunately they didn't have you guys
[Music]
I like this one
[Music]
let's go get this son of a [ __ ]
the group decide to suit up and head out
and they use Captain Marvel as a guide
and find Thanos on Titan 2 which is in
ruins - once again - the life they're
slowly being ripped apart by the snap
Danis cannot see all the damage that he
is done and the group fight him the
reason that Thanos is wearing armor now
is because in infinity war he arrogantly
didn't use it and almost died at the end
of the film even with the Infinity
stones and gauntlet complete he has been
expecting a counter-attack and is ready
for it easily beating the Avengers again
and this time warning them not to come
back they returned to earth pretty
disheveled which is when ant-man shows
up he tells them that he can use the
quantum realm to travel through time and
that they can split off into teams to
try and take the Infinity stones back
thus preventing the snap the avengers
want to go all-out so Black Widow heads
out to recruit hawkeye whose family all
died in the snap they suit up and break
off into the groups traveling to
different points in MCU history but when
the Infinity stones were in play Iron
Man and ant-man go to the Battle of New
York which we've seen in leaked photos
to get the mind stone rocket nebula and
war machine go to the end of guardians
of the galaxy Thor and Hulk return to
Thor the dark world to get the aether
and tesseract
Captain Marvel goes to the soulstone and
Black Widow and Hawkeye sneak in to
Katmandu to get the time stone and this
is kind of where the plot saw gets a bit
murky so that's everything we know so
far for definite there are also several
indicators that Professor Hulk will
appear in the film and this has been
confirmed by action figures and concept
art for those who don't know professor
Hulk is the perfect mix between Hulk and
Bruce Banner and the evolved character
features the brains of Bibi and the
strength of the lean Mean Green Machine
it's probably the perfect match for
Thanos who not only has the Hulk's
strength but also possesses a high level
of intelligence I can definitely see
this being brought into the film and it
would add a neat little twist on the
character going forward while some read
numerous leaks on the rest of the movie
they all seem to contradict the confirm
reports so it's a bit difficult wading
through all the chaff to bring you the
facts overall though I'd of course love
to hear your thoughts on the movie and
if there's any other confirm leaks that
I missed out on if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my full breakdown of the
third trailer which would be linked at
the end of this
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]